it's not prepared to do it needs more
reform but I love you more than you you
know another sort of thread throughout
the story of these years is coming to
grips with the potential but also the
shortcomings of multilateralism
particularly the United Nations all
right i mean remember this era begins
with george HW bush pronouncing the new
world order and you know expressing high
hopes for the united nations for working
george HW bush had been an ambassador
the united nations in the early 1970s he
loved being a bastard of the united
nations so for him this was a dream come
true right and then so in it but then
throughout that era we see you know it's
sort of a story of people kind of having
to come to accept that the UN has real
limits and you know the cost of maybe
putting too much hope in too much power
many ways to an institution like the UN
but at the same time we could we
couldn't get rid of it right and so you
know it's it's when Clinton leaves
office the United Nations is an
institution that there were still
working in but we had found you know in
Kosovo was it was a classic example in
which we the United States had tried
very hard to get UN security council
Council authorization to act in Kosovo
to you know be able to sort of to stop
the Milosevic the dictators repression
of a Muslim minority in Kosovo they were
unable to get you in Security Council
authorization to do so because Russia
and China would or would veto the UN
Security Council so they used another
institution like NATO I think the
difference is between bush and Clinton
Bush for Bush 43 in clinton and i think
the next president with a McCain or
obama will face and i think we are
seeing differences when mccain and obama
is that bush came in office believing
that the u.s. really didn't need any you
know UN authorization
or any kind of international blessing so
to speak to legitimize its actions all
right that you know of course it'd be
fine if we had partners but we don't
really need partners we're powerful
enough we don't you know it'd be nice
just to share the burden but there's no
sort of inherent legitimacy that the UN
lens and I think the Clint
administration had a different approach
I mean they were they cared more about
having partners not just for
instrumental reasons to share the burden
but because they believe that having
partners bestowed a certain sense of
legitimacy on on American power
essentially but that didn't mean they
were they would they would sort of only
work with partners I mean I think with
Clinton the mantra was you know together
if we can you know alone if we must and
with Bush it was the opposite right it
was you know loan if we can together if
we must I mean the impulse for Bush was
that we didn't they didn't want to work
with allies that much because they
weren't interested in having any kind of
hindrances on the use of American power
and morva they didn't think we really
needed it I think what's interesting
looking at the current campaign I mean
Obama i think is squarely within this
sort of democratic tradition big d
democratic tradition when it comes to
multilateralism and I think you know
he's made very clear he believes in
strong institution global institutions
he believes in you know having the UN
work as well as a can but he's also
realistic about its potential not to
work right but he's committed to try to
fix it and as well let's think about
building other institutions John McCain
is also interesting on this I mean he's
talked more about global institutions
than any Republican you know
presidential candidate as for quite some
time it's interesting in 1996 the
campaign we recount this in the book
then the Republican nominee Bob Dole you
know used you know the UN and the UN
secretary-general boutros boutros-ghali
is like a punch line he would sort of
purposefully you know mispronounce
boutros-ghali name on the campaign trail
I mean they really tried to use the UN
as like a as a stick to beat up Clinton
with now you have have McCain saying
much different things about the UN he's
clearly not as sort of he's clearly more
in the conservative tradition but it
seems to understand
the message I think that we've learned
over the last seven or eight years that
unfortunately think we knew in the 90s
and then we sort of you know the bush
administration came in and didn't want
to accept it but I think the Republicans
have gotten the message that
institutions do matter I mean we
shouldn't try we have to be realistic
about what they can actually be and we
have to be true to ourselves in the
sense of you know no US president should
ever you know have let any international
body have a veto over what we deem to be
an American interest particularly when
our security is at stake but I think
people understand that that institutions
matter we it's good for our actions you
seem legit let's good that part well
McCain has actually floated it Obama has
not although some of his more prominent
advisors have been in their own personal
capacities supportive of it I think that
it's both less and more than we should
make it okay Oh erson alee give McCain
some credit for being a conservative
who's willing to talk about global
institutions and as someone who is a
liberal and who believes in you know
making global institutions stronger and
that that that's in America's interest
to do so I think it's significant that a
Republican feels the need to talk about
institutional ism now what McCain is
saying and I think this point is is true
and I don't think many would argue on
either side of political I about this is
that our current architecture
institutional architecture for the globe
view NGA is not really relevant to the
current power configuration of the goal
right i mean you know the g8 doesn't
have doesn't have countries like China
and India and Brazil in it and it's
supposed to be the the you know the
leading economies of the world right the
UN Security Council is in many ways you
know the the permanent members with a
veto the five permanent five members
were the powers who won World War two
right so it's it's reflective of the
moment 1945 not 2008
so the first part of McCain's message
which is we need institutions to be more
relevant to today's challenge I think
everyone agrees with right his answer is
only answer so far is this league of
democracies again on the one hand I give
a conservative credit for talking about
the importance of global institutions I
think you know my view is the more
institutions the merrier but here's the
reality I don't know many other leading
democracies who are really enthusiastic
about the idea of joining or creating a
league of democracies and without that I
think it's hard to see how something
like this gets off the ground just as a
practical matter but I think it would be
unwise for liberals to sort of discount
it completely because you don't want to
look as though you're sort of defending
the rights of authoritarian regimes you
know who are we sort of used their
special role in in councils like the UN
Security Council to thwart action and
places like Darfur where there's many
liberals who believe as do i that we
probably need more